uh who would you put in your like uh
your Bay Area rapper Mount Rushmore
um
that stuff
um
I feel like three slots already taken so
the fourth One's Gonna Be the
controversy but guys damn same for
yourself I mean if you really if you
really think about it bro
like impact and all this [ __ ] bro
I really like you can really make an
argument for I am too bro up there for
what Fair like you know what I'm saying
for what spawned from him okay so we're
putting imsu up there
Mac Mac Dre short 40. those are the four
I like it
I mean like I know you know that's that
that's me that's you know what I'm
saying like no I mean I don't feel like
people give Sue enough credit oh one
thousand percent bro I mean like bro
like how like
like how great are you if if you're the
only one that's great
um you know what I'm saying like how
many people have done spawned off from
the I am Sue tree from from the tree
yeah you know what I'm saying and like I
don't think
a lot of people Overlook it because
we're still like that it's like still
like happening you know I'm saying 100
it's still happening right now yeah
people are still like living in that
like you know people still do you guys
still talk often you and two yeah I mean
we talk here and there like you know
like you know he's like we we both had a
busy you know I'm saying got a lot of
[ __ ] going on but yeah I just talked to
him not so long ago
great guy awesome great awesome guy bro
yeah still a great friend of mine still
my brother to this day yeah how's uh
how's John doing yeah John I brought out
John at the chase Center you know what
I'm saying he's awesome you know what
I'm saying like he he had you know he
had had a situation like a couple years
ago or like right when the pandemic
happened but he's cool he's he's smooth
he's you know back moving around he's
he's gravy you know what I'm saying